[Música]
bangalore con 11 millones de habitantes
es una ciudad que ha crecido demasiado
rápido
la ciudad conocida como el silicon
valley de la india se desmorona ahora
bajo el hormigón y la contaminación
los ríos lagos y arroyos en particular
están siendo devastados por los residuos
y las aguas residuales
si ven aquí a mí una situación que andan
mal igawa decidió abordar
y es de hace cinco años este antiguo
ingeniero se propuso limpiar los lagos
de bangalore uno por uno y devolverles
la vida un proyecto gigantesco todos
estos proyectos comienzan de la misma
manera primero hay que vaciar
completamente el lago
miren el lamentable estado de esta agua
está lleno de hierba mala y el olor es
nauseabundo el lago se llenó de aguas
residuales hay metano dentro y bacterias
tenemos que devolverle la vida muy
rápidamente
una vez vaciado dejará que se llene de
agua de lluvia
las aguas residuales se trataran en un
canal construido al lado
tendremos un canal en el que
seleccionaremos los residuos de plástico
las botellas serán atrapados de los 850
lagos de bangalore más de 500 están
completamente contaminados
en el corazón de la ciudad este estanque
ya no es una masa de agua sino que se ha
convertido en una colección de basura de
todo tipo
hay muchos residuos aquí
miren incluso hay neumáticos
y van a permanecer aquí durante miles de
años y fue la constatación de este
abismo medioambiental lo que le llevó a
renunciar a su antiguo cargo para
dedicarse por completo a la restauración
de los lagos
antes la gente bebía de esta agua pero
ahora ni siquiera podemos quedarnos aquí
no siquiera podemos tocar el agua es
patético tan triste que me dan ganas de
llenar
apoyado económicamente por el gobierno
local y por donaciones de empresas
privadas ganan la liga wat ya ha salvado
15 lagos
este será el decimosexto dentro de tres
meses habrá terminado de llenarse
será hermoso para conservarlo una vez
finalizado el proyecto
anand cuenta con la población local para
cuidarlo
hola a todos
esta mañana invito a un centenar de
personas a plantar árboles alrededor del
lago el objetivo es concientizar los
acerca de la protección del medio
ambiente
así que esta fila se planta aquí y las
otras allí para que aquí nadie tire los
residuos domésticos porque la población
también es responsable de la
contaminación de los lagos
hay tantos lagos que están llenos de
residuos de plástico
intentaremos mantener esté limpio ese es
el mensaje que hemos recibido
como prueba del éxito del trabajo de
anand este lago del sur de bangalore se
limpió por completo hace cinco años y
sigue estando perfectamente limpio en la
actualidad y quien sí
mira que clara es esta agua no huele mal
es transparente es impecable los lagos
no son solo agua en la superficie son
los pulmones de la tierra por eso
tenemos que preservarlo si por su acción
y dedicación annan malig aguad fue uno
de los cuatro indios invitados a glasgow
en escocia para participar en la pasada
cumbre de la cob 26